I know we're in what seems like a freer
culture right now where people don't
have to be bound by as much what their
own family of origin says they should be
doing and and people seem to be okay
with just kind of being who they are it
seems like we're coming into our own
like that and I know this is I'm just
like doing a bunch of doublespeak but
let's talk about people that tell you
you they give you advice or not in the
industry and they're telling you you
shouldn't do that but part of it might
be because they actually won't allow
themselves to live the life they want to
live be with the person they want to be
with yeah choose to go outside the sort
of status quo of of what their identity
says they're supposed to be the human
condition baby yeah right it happens all
the time
I mean I'm sure that you both felt it oh
I've yeah but I've never been one to
care about like convention in fact I
might be more of a nah that's weird
I'm kind of an yeah and I and
it's like I can't like a song and
everybody likes right now and then I
hear years later and go actually that's
pretty good
but oh because it was so popular at that
time I was cringed so I have that
disease I know that that is its own
affliction there it's the contrarian
complex I don't know what it is uh it
has to do with authority okay let's do a
thoracotomy have with them that's where
it all stems from anyway yes they do so
you know it takes courage to be an
artist takes an enormous courage to be
an artist whatever your your art is it's
not easy sitting down and pouring your
heart into a script right even if it is
a story you've created it's still your
blood sweat and tears right in your
heart on that page that takes guts to
sit in front of a camera and act out
those words and perform it and bring it
to life with a point of view incredibly
hard incredibly hard same for directing
same for the production same for all of
it it's all challenging so I like I
salute all
because it takes enormous courage and
that kind of courage doesn't go
unnoticed and when people who aren't
chasing their dream or going after what
they really want whatever it may be
doesn't necessarily have to be in the
arts right whatever it may be when they
aren't doing that and they have fallen
in step two conventional wisdom to
groupthink right and I know a little bit
about that because I got caught up in
that little group thing that is
extremely detrimental to one's health
and happiness and safety and yeah
jealousy comes out of that and so
condemnation it's the easiest thing in
the world right we'll all pick an attack
on each other constantly instead of
supporting each other and encouraging
each other and then you see that the
people who are the most successful in
any industry and any any walk of life
who are doing what they love love what
they're doing they're happier than we're
peacefull and we're successful right
they're the most generous they're the
most supportive the most loving with
their time their resources their money
whatever it may be right because I think
they see and they understand inherently
how tough it is to put yourself out on
the line to put yourself out there let
yourself be seen warts-and-all right
yeah which is going back to you know we
all sit there and beat ourselves up oh
my god what were they thinking about it
was that terrible as that awful I'll
never work again right relax man take it
easy it's okay that's why I think it's
great you go out and find a mentor
someone who's you know succeeded it
doesn't even have to be in the same
thing you're doing in fact I really
encourage everyone to go out outside of
their comfort zone into completely
unknown territories and businesses and
industries and start to learn about them
if you have an interest in it not just
you know willy-nilly hey I'm gonna go
into the auto manufacturing you know
plant today you know if you're
interested in autos great but whatever
it may be right and just go put yourself
out there go to a workshop they have go
a seminar go to a convention right go to
a meeting and and see what's going on
and and necessarily that starts to
inform you and on ways that you would
never never have expected really in the
most wonderful ways you know have you
ever had an audition where it went
horrible and then it turns out you got
the part
ha ha ha and you were shocked like you
thought they didn't like you they didn't
even look up from there you know it's
just some story like that only if we
count every audition yeah no kidding
yeah that's happened that's happened
yeah quite a few times actually and that
is that's that's one of those times
where I stopped and thought to myself
son you don't know anything
you have got preconceived ideas you've
got presuppositions you're you're just
like man that's maybe you need to
rethink some things alright and and
that's a good thing that's a good thing
right because it takes you outside of
yourself and that's not what everyone
else is doing right you can live your
whole life very comfortably doing what
you're supposed to do go to school get
good grades graduate get a job buy a
house get your mortgage have a family
have kids dah dah dah dah dah and that's
all wonderful but if it's not your thing
then it's not your thing and you need to
find out what your thing is and then go
and do that and doing that is going to
necessarily bring up what you're talking
about people judging you or people being
jealous of you or people trying to pull
you down or or people you know trying to
you know make it hard for you in any
number of ways you know usually it's
passive aggressiveness but you've got to
find that strength within yourself and
just keep soldiering on and fear do you
think as we all hear like these buzz
phrases about oh it's you know fears
love turning you know whatever the
different things are button right when
you actually see it happening and it
could be from
people that you went to school with that
you were close in college let's say or
whatever and then you go on a slightly
different path and you see their fear
reaction yeah and it becomes lonely
because you say well do I comply and
stay with the group and now I have
somewhere to go
yeah or do I do what I want to do and
then maybe the phone stops ringing yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's crazy town
right there
yeah it's it can be the truth for a lot
of people whatever their it could be for
entrepreneurs who want to start a
business and people say you're
absolutely don't leave that good job
great that's a great point so yeah that
that yeah that's how all that happens to
me it has happened happens a lot less to
me now but you know that's because I've
made a concerted effort to you know like
really keep myself more focused and more
aware of what I'm doing and what's going
on in any given situation that I am like
I said you know we're 'no screech ice
the more awareness I have the more
choice I have and the more choice I have
I'm always going to naturally choose
what serves me in the situation better
you know so you know entrepreneurs and
artists are really kind of one of the
same thing because they all have the
same struggle you know you're creating
something from nothing
whatever it may be and you're gonna fail
more often you succeed that's that's
just how it's going to go and that
requires a lot of courage and you're
gonna have to deal with a lot of doubts
and a lot of fears and a lot of worries
and a lot of resentments and jealousies
and and and and and you have to find
your way through that because there is
no one way and anyone tries to tell you
oh well this is the way you do it is
either lying to you bullshitting you or
trying to sell you something really
simple right all three or all three at
the same time which is an especially
distasteful combination so be nice to
yourself man find out what works for you
and you're gonna find out what works for
you by finding out what doesn't work for
you constantly
fear everyone has it you know
Brene brown became very you know popular
with her TED talk and then you know her
appearances on national television I
think it's genius in its simplicity and
it's it's you know showing your
vulnerability you know look I don't have
the answers I certainly don't in fact
the more I learned the more I know I
don't know anything and the grand scheme
of things huh who the hell am i when you
show yourself right when you put
yourself out there when you let yourself
be seen your words your artwork your
direction whatever it may be your music
your lyrics whenever it is your dancing
your your body your hair your everything
that's necessarily a vulnerable place
but that's where all the magic happens
right letting people come in and see you
and feel your humanity right and see it
for all of its flaws because we all have
those flaws we all do and in this
industry it's really easy to put forth
an image and have a narrative and then
get that thing stamped boom boom boom
boom and you show up across all these
you know television shows and all these
radio interviews and all these podcasts
and you know or you know you're very
pensive or whatever it may be but that's
not the whole picture
it never is right it's just what's in
the frame and what's in the frames
what's in the frame but that's not the
whole story right so don't be afraid to
let someone know you don't know what's
going on or you know what yeah I'm
scared man I don't know how this is
gonna go that happens in you you know I
go and do a scene and it's a very
emotional scene or it's a very dangerous
scene or very physical scene god I hope
this goes well alright but you know I've
done my work I've made strong choices
and I know what the story being told is
and I know what's going on and then I
got to just trust the other actor with
me I got to trust the writing the words
on the page and the setting and the
dynamic and just go let it happen
similarly I think it would be really
well it would be great advice and great
thing to start to add that into your
life as well kind of coming back full
circle art saved my life I learned that
through art
you